Jimmy Kimmel has some serious doubts
about bachelor star Colden Underwood's
virginity we're still talking about cold
and Underwood's virginity it is still
happening guys the 51 year old late
night hosts question the reality stars
sexual experience on The Ellen DeGeneres
Show check this out
you believe The Bachelor is a virgin
well he says he is I know he does you
used to tell my mother that too you know
I think I think maybe that's the deal is
that maybe he doesn't want his mom to
know that he's been you know because I
can't like fferent I mean if I were to
announce like hey I just want everyone
to know I'm an adult version people
would say like yeah that makes sense
yeah that's when the conversation turned
to a shirtless pic of the 27 year old
bachelor and he made this pretty
convincing argument but you look at this
guy and it's like there's no ways
there's it's just impossible that's not
a virgin so you really you think he's
lying I mean are you being honest about
this you asked him if he would submit to
a polygraph test and they said no that's
interesting mm-hmm yeah so you think
this whole thing is so that women are
like y'all teach you that oh I didn't
even think about that I mean why else
say you're a virgin unless it's gonna
get girls to go let me then you can't
really be bad in bed if you're not
compared to anyone you know what I mean
all right ash what do you think about
this I am I don't even watch The
Bachelor and I'm so sick of hearing
about gold in other words it's a double
standard totally can you imagine if this
was a woman no and it's like it's for
the Bachelorette and everyone we're
talking about it every single second of
the day this is not the first time the
Kimmel has questioned Underwood's at
virginity we keep hearing your about
you're a virgin but you're probably you
probably had sex 185 times by night when
the former NFL player stopped by Jimmy
Kimmel Live earlier this month he asked
him if he made it to the fantasy suite
while filming the hit ABC show um I will
say like the fantasy suite was the most
pivotal week of my journey okay she did
go to the fantasy suite yes I made it to
that week okay do they have um are you
miked
up there
you're miked up until you open up the
door and then right when you get on the
other side of the door they'd be my cue
they do they take it off or they tell
you it's they're not listening they take
it off then you take it off okay I
checked the rooms again don't watch the
show really tired of hearing about
Colin's virginity and you know who else
was tired of it
Dalton as you said people asking you
about the virginity thing are you sick
of talking about it yet I am yeah I just
think it's really important to to just
break free of all sorts of labels it
would be the same thing if you were like
Oh football players like I'm more than
that you know there's a lot of different
things dog-lover I mean I have much of
different titles that I like to hold on
to but I also have a lot more little
things that makes me into the person I
am it's been a topic of conversation
since his virginity reveal on The
Bachelorette um I still AM I am the
virgin really and Colin's been
explaining his reasoning since July so
basically forever forever I'm waiting
for the right heart and let me explain
that because it sounds a little corny it
sounds a little cheesy I'm waiting for
somebody to match my intensity someone
that's going to be into me as much as
I'm into them somebody that I'm so madly
in love with and that I could share that
special moment with that's what I'm
waiting for and that's what I'm looking
forward to
so clearly ash and I are like super over
it I'm tired are you tired are we tired
you tell us we want to know and be sure
to subscribe to all things et until next
time I'm at Halle underscore Stephen and
I'm at ash Carlson and I'm tired and I'm
tired too bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]